some large US companies are promising
their employees bonuses after the
president signs the tax bill into law
AT&T says it'll give 200,000 of its
employees $1,000 each Comcast also
promises $1,000 to more than a hundred
thousand workers and Boeing plans to
allocate an extra 300 million dollars
for job training facility upgrades and
charitable giving a few hours after
their white house celebration
congressional Republicans released a new
plan to prevent a government shutdown
money will run out at midnight tomorrow
if Congress cannot make this deal the
GOP plan would keep the government going
for another four weeks of January 19th
it would pay for the Children's Health
Insurance Program or chip as it's called
until March 31st an extend authorization
of the Foreign Intelligence Surveillance
Act that's known as FISA House
Democratic leaders say they will not
support the plan unless it also gives
legal status to so-called dreamers their
people brought to the US illegally as
children
dancy nor is a republican strategist and
former advisor to House Speaker Paul
Ryan he was also senior advisor to the
romney-ryan presidential campaign dan
good morning so we saw essentially
yesterday after the Democrats called the
president's tax plan and the Republicans
tax plan sort of a fantasy we saw all
these companies come on say well we are
gonna give people money we are gonna do
more hiring will they actually follow
through on those promises well I think
that the news you saw overnight with
these companies announcing these end of
your bonuses it's a little bit of you
know it's kind of some gimmicks here I
mean I don't think we should overstate
the significance it's good it's positive
but it's not we shouldn't overstate the
significance the real question is will a
large chunk of the country receive some
kind of tax relief a and B will
companies really start investing in the
growth of their companies capital
infrastructure hiring more people we
will know that very quickly so
everyone's making these projections you
know the deficits gonna blow out out of
the control and too many people are
gonna get a tax cut not enough people in
need attack so you're seeing all these
estimates from these different you know
independent you know projectors we can
know pretty quickly in early 2018 on
with holding you know people when they
get their paychecks they're gonna either
get a tax cut that they're gonna see
right then and there January February
March or not well we're gonna see
companies making budgets pretty quickly
your old boss told us yesterday that
that you know the polls show that this
is a very unpopular bill but he said as
soon as people start getting write the
checks you're talking about that their
opinions will change right which is
exactly what happened with the Bush tax
cuts in 2002 yeah they front-loaded the
relief and that actually helped
Republicans when they're heading into
the 2002 elections the bill is also
unpopular though I believe because the
president United States did not in a
sustained way despite all the hoopla
yesterday he did not make the case for
this bill it is very rare for a major
domestic policy initiative to gain
public support if you don't have the
president's out there delivering
speeches holding town hall meetings
giving addresses from the Oval Office
it's what President Obama did with
Obamacare it's what President Reagan did
with the 86 tax reform act I mean you
need the White House out there that was
missing from this you know that came
back to hurt them yeah I think I think
congressional Republicans have a lot of
work to do over the next year explaining
this bill because I don't think most
people understand it they will see
potentially the benefits if the benefits
are real but but it's it's gonna take
some work explaining it putting oh they
sure gave them a lot of credit yesterday
dan yesterday on the White House lawn
but what did the Republicans get right
this time do you think well look they
even different unlike health care reform
where they agreed on repeal but there
wasn't a consensus about what to replace
Obamacare with in this case there was
real agreement going back years and
years and years on many of the
provisions in this tax reform bill
particularly the corporate tax rate cut
so Republicans there wasn't a lot of
infighting over the substance of this
one a and B I think Republicans got
spooked by the fight over Obamacare and
they realized wait a minute we're now we
got proximity to a midterm now we've got
what less than a year about a year
before the midterm elections and we
don't have anything to show for our time
governing with this Republican in
unified republican government we need
something to show we didn't have
anything to show before and I also think
McConnell and Ryan did a good job of
getting all the different factions on
board beforehand which was a mistake
they made with
the Obamacare fight they didn't have
them on board before it all right
dancing or thank you good to be would
have a good Christmas IRA days and
Counting all right good to see you guys